let's bring in live from the southern
border Anna giratelli with the
Washington examiner she is in El Paso
Texas and Todd benzman a fellow at the
center for immigration studies is right
across the border in Matamoros Mexico
thanks to the both of you for being here
Todd will begin with you what are you
seeing on the other side of the Border
there in Mexico less than 24 hours
before title 42 is set to expire
right well uh right now as we're
speaking there is a brand new unit
of the Texas Department of Public Safety
that has just been deployed to the other
side right now they are yelling and
shouting Alto Alto to a large group of
uh immigrants who are right down here
trying to cross uh the Department of
Public Safety is defending a long row of
razor wire uh and there's the question
is what what would happen if the
immigrants actually climbed up and you
know got into contact with them I'm told
that they will be armed with uh pepper
balls uh to uh fire or potentially fire
uh and that they are or under orders to
not let any immigrants up this Riverbank
and this comes after just days and even
weeks of just uh thousands of immigrants
from this Camp a very vast Camp here
pouring over the Border pouring over the
Border in coordination between the
United States border patrol and the
Mexican immigration service
uh the U.S tells Mexico when to let them
in uh and then they'll cross in uh and
when to stop them and then they'll stop
them for a while and in the meantime
Texas DPS is like yeah we're not having
that uh we're gonna go ahead and uh get
right in your way so it'll be
interesting to see how that works out
you know Todd you were talking about uh
the group of people trying trying to to
get crossed and you can hear them
yelling right now it's three o'clock in
the morning is it always this active
just 24 7.
yeah
yes it has been 24 7. uh you have
immigrants who are showing up at the bus
station here bus after bus all day all
night uh from other parts of Mexico
they're coming to Matamoras they tell me
because the Biden Administration is
letting them in uh this is the spot
where if they can get across the buying
the administration is going to parole
them on into they're not going to 42
them they're going to parole the
majority of them into you know New
Jersey New York Denver Chicago they're
they're moving in all over the country
our country and so uh it's this
incredible enticement and
incentivization and they're explaining
that to me when I ask them why are you
coming here so it's uh that that's
really what's going on here there are
other ones who are in this Camp who do
not uh plan to go until they find out
after title 42 which is midnight tonight
uh whether that's going to continue so
if it does continue they will you'll see
a whole lot more they're telling me that
if the Americans are letting them in
they are going in a big group they're
all a big mass group yeah before we
bring it in I want to follow up on what
you just mentioned in your previous
answer
you're reporting that Biden officials
are literally coordinating with Mexican
officials to let migrants swim over come
over to Brownsville Texas it's part of a
coordinated effort it seems to me that
it's all about Optics not wanting to
have too many people crowd at the border
at any one particular time in order to
facilitate the processing in a more
orderly fashion walk us through in more
detail exactly what you've seen exactly
what you've heard
yes well I just broke the story
yesterday at cis.org Center for
immigration studies that the Mexican
immigration officials here
are using a WhatsApp an encrypted
WhatsApp channel uh with the Americans
and they are coordinating uh groups on
this side to swim over to that side uh
and when enough have gone over usually
150 100 200 uh then the immigration
authorities stop everybody and make them
wait until they get a call from the
Americans to say okay bring the next
group and I watch this happen all day
long and all night long until I finally
thought this is strange and I started
asking around why are you why are you
letting them in this way and uh five
different Mexican immigration officers
explained uh yeah this is all part of a
coordinated effort with the Americans
that is happening and it's a bit
troubling because uh you know that shows
kind of an acquiescence by the Biden
Administration uh that to to the illegal
immigrants to Illegal immigration
generally not to block stop up and deter
but to facilitate and accommodate in a
way that is the least visible and at
least has the least uh problematic
political Optics yeah concerning to say
the least with that reporting Todd Anna
I want to go to you now you know it's no
it's no secret that El Paso is a
disaster right now we've seen videos
we've seen pictures we've spoken to
people who live there you were actually
with ice and CBP Patrol agents on
Tuesdays they were clearing people out
downtown
we know that was an effort that they did
but what is border patrol saying their
fears are you know come midnight tonight
when title 42 does end and what are you
seeing at the same time
yeah I spoke with the head of border
patrol rival Ortiz yesterday uh just
less than 12 hours ago actually and he
made a really startling statement he
said they believe a border patrol the
worst is over they believe this is the
surge for title 42 it's coming before it
actually ends and he was saying he
doesn't expect to hit the 18 000
apprehensions per day we saw 11 000
apprehensions yesterday but they think
we're going to be in the clear it's sort
of like we're climaxing now and it's
gonna be uh better than what we what
we've seen the last few days and when
you say the worst is over are you
talking about just for El Paso
we're talking Nationwide
all right okay do you agree with that I
mean based upon what you're seeing on
the ground and the just overall feel
that one can get when they're reporting
from a community like you are do you
agree with that statement
you know I think in El Paso we've seen
um we've seen new spots where people are
crossing groups of several hundred there
are 2 000 about 10 miles outside of town
the other day and it's probably where
they're going to keep Crossing I think
there's a rush to get in I'm speaking
with Venezuelan migrants yesterday
downtown at the church and they were
saying we wanted to get in the four
titles 42 ends because then after title
42 you get arrested at the border you're
banned for five years from seeking
admission again through this CBP one app
so for a lot of people they're trying to
beat the clock which I think we sort of
forgot about in the lead up to this
so to follow up quickly we've been
basically assuming that the migrants
themselves did not know about the change
in law that would occur at the end of
title 42. you're basically saying hey
these migrants know darn well the law
and they know how to manipulate it and
that's why maybe they came in advance of
title 42 expiring correct
you know I think it's really a mix right
because I don't think the average
American really understands title 42
necessarily I think migrants but I was
speaking with they heard back in
Venezuela yeah you can come now we did a
story on it but they're giving out you
know they'll take care of you there's
food there's shelter there's benefits to
be had they're willing to help you and
so when they came to El Paso and they're
living on the street 2500 people that we
saw this last week it was a very
different reality that they experienced
and I I think surprised them frankly
yeah I bet it didn't I'm sure it
surprised the people of El Paso too who
were dealing with it and the business
owners downtown dealing with what they
were dealing with you said there was
2500 people of migrants being housed in
a church I mean I Can Only Imagine The
Strain that puts on not just border
patrol but the city and the people who
live there who are not used to this type
of situation uh Todd and Anna thank you
so much for this Insight this morning we
really appreciate it and Todd stay safe
over there
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis